[Music]
come on
it's ready
[Music]
just doing us now nice work everyone
it's over for all of Central City
[Music]
Barry
or too late
like in the courtroom why didn't ya I
can't save this time episode 4 15 and
her flash time there is a terrorist
downtown central city who has taken over
a Argus
trailer that inside of it has a nuclear
bomb very arrives and he finds out that
he's too late his car is already gone
critical
I know we have to keep moving till we
figure out a way to stop it so for the
whole episode we're essentially in flash
time it's up to Barry and the return of
Jay Garrick and Jesse quick to try to
figure out how to stop an explosion that
has already started we can't run
everyone outside the city we're talking
hundreds of thousands of people even if
there were more than just the two of us
there's not enough time
check this out space the final frontier
now you see it now you don't that is the
warping signature of someone moving into
pocket dimension hey everybody we
finally got our flash family episode
let's break it down and there is a new
round of the plastering giveaway all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video they
explain a little bit more about what's
going on here in the actress that plays
Jesse quick violet bean did an interview
where she sort of explains her timeline
during the film and the whole reason for
why she comes to the city but we sort of
got that scene with Harrison wells it's
a seal last week you're not gonna know
unless you invite her the rest of that
explainer from Jessie quick side of
things is that she's on earth too and
she gets one of those cubes but there's
nothing on it so she's like what the
hell and that's why she comes to earth
one it's not that she gets the apology
and decides to come it's just that the
cube doesn't have anything on it so it
sounds like Jessie quick is already
there or she arrives just after they
learn about the threat of the bomb and
then they get jay garrick's help but you
look at him during the trailer here like
Jessie quick is this young person very
optimistic like hey we can save the day
but see the look on jay garrick's face
like he's been through a lot of
adventures like this and you can tell
that he's not super optimistic like who
this is this is bad barry i don't know
if we're gonna be able to solve this
problem they even mentioned the comic
book easter egg about running everyone
out of the city like wally west did
during that JLA comic that i've been
talking about for the past couple of
weeks it seems like the reason why
they're explaining that they can't do
that is because the bomb has already
gone off when Barry learns about it for
the first time so however fast you think
they are collectively it's just not
quite fast enough to run everyone out
and it's not like they're gonna blow up
Central City because they had to
reconstruct it for the rest of the
season it would spill into season 5 like
they had the Wally Starro episode like
back during the first half of the season
then they called back to that on the
Fiddler's tour dates she had to cancel a
tour date in March of this year like it
hasn't even happened yet
because they're still rebuilding the
city from the Storrow problem
you have to imagine that like blowing up
Central City would just be the most
ridiculous thing ever
but I love the fact that this is an
Argos bomb like Lila is probably gonna
have a little explaining to do and I
think the reason why we haven't seen her
on arrow in a long time is because the
actress has been cast on another TV show
we'll just have Diggle pass a note to
Lyla come see the flashes they have
something to talk to you about really
upset about this bomb that looks like is
crackling with Speed Force energy but
they don't really explain what kind of
bomb it is just that the countdown clock
has gone off and it's starting to
explode as Barry goes into flash time so
they're like literally is no time to run
everyone out of the city so on the list
of possible solutions like there's the
episode 10 trial the flash solution
where you port the blasts to earth 15
but it kind of feels like they're trying
to subvert that like oh you know I use
this really easy technique way back
during this episode where I went into
flash time but the solution this time
isn't supposed to be that easy like you
can't just run around that import it to
another earth right now best solution is
probably using that pocket dimension
they just discovered at the end of last
week's episode like if you're gonna
explode it somewhere in Flash's can
throw things into other dimensions like
throwing the Philosopher's Stone into
the Speed Force maybe they can find a
way to throw this bomb into a pocket
dimension which who knows what kind of
problems that might create that is the
warping signature of someone moving into
pocket dimension the other side of the
equation that says that flashes do
eventually run out of energy so they
can't stay in flash time like you see
Barry slowly going crazier and crazier
is he's in this flopsweat like oh my god
I can't do this so given the way they've
cut the trailer now it seems a little
more misleading like at this point where
he's talking to iris I can't do this and
he's in this crazy sweat Jesse quick
could have already arrived and is doing
something else it's just the way they
pitched the episode is that it's
supposed to completely take place during
flash time so it sounds like they find
out about the bomb pretty quickly and
then he goes with the montage of trying
to port it away using Cisco's vibe
ability freeze it using killer frost
ability then goes to the flashes like
Jesse quick and Jay Garrick but I know
everybody's wondering if they're gonna
kill one of the flashes because of Young
Justice season 2 and because of the
injustice comics but there are a couple
different ways that flashes have died in
the last couple of years you
have young justice Wally West that got
hit with the energy from this blast and
it sort of dissipated him they were
really cryptic about what was happening
but I think we all assumed that he was
getting ported into the Speed Force as
pure energy the way the TV show deals
with the death of flashes is relatively
ambiguous like you don't know exactly
what's going on and I think that's just
because they want to build themselves
some room down the road in case they
want to bring characters back like the
reverse-flash coming back during season
two then playing it fast and loose with
the way time works on the TV show like
is this terminator rules is it Back to
the Future rules what are you doing here
real like the simplest explainer is is
that characters like the reverse-flash
will always come back characters like
Jay Garrick Jesse quick they'll always
come back in some form or another but I
guess it wouldn't be the flash TV show
if they were able to solve everyone's
problems and there wasn't any price to
pay by the end of the episode like
that's kind of been the running theme
for the last couple of episodes this
season is is that like yeah they have
some big victory but it usually it's
undercut with some great loss like they
try to save the Fiddler's they make the
thinking cap but it doesn't work and she
gets assimilated anyway so important
thing to remember is is that Jesse quick
is going to be guest starring on episode
15 of legends of tomorrow Constantine is
also going to be crossing over with that
episode it's called necromancing the
stone so I don't want to make any
premature predictions before seeing this
episode of the flash but given what
happens to her during this episode I
think we have a much better idea for how
she crosses over to legends of tomorrow
because the actress violet bean said
that the way that she shows up on
legends of tomorrow is a big surprise
for the fans making it sound like it
wasn't quite as much of a bummer so
there's not a whole lot you can pull out
of that like she was really trying to
not be spoilery for whatever was gonna
be happening during this flash episode
we just post all your theories in the
comments below
obviously I'll post my Easter Egg video
later tonight on us the giveaway winner
when I post that there's also an
infinity war video that I'm working on
or maybe I've already posted it as I'm
posting this trailer video there's a
couple videos that I'm trying to get out
today so you can click here for
brand-new infinity war and click here
for that flash video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight